hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
welcome to this week's winners on a
wednesday
so thing is every single week people
love winners wednesday because i
interview
one of my success students who's become
financially free by using the strategies
that i teach
now this wednesday is a little bit
different because i'm going to be
interviewing my parents
now they're not my success students in
fact they helped me get into property
were really influential and you're going
to be hearing all about that but they
have gone on to do great things in
property themselves
and you're going to hear what they've
done this is going to be a very
interesting interview
i'm almost a little bit nervous about it
if i'm perfectly honest but i tell you
something you're going to learn a lot
there's going to be some golden nuggets
so my advice is get
comfy get comfy get a notepad and a pen
take good notes and enjoy
so this is not the normal typical
interview i don't think
you've only been on my youtube channel
once i think once when you came when i
bought the castle
yes when you were on briefly but as i
put my timeline out
um and literally talked about my first
property
which you tim put in your name and then
in fact let me talk about let's talk
about that that first property
um that i put you put in your name we
had no contract or anything did we
nope so what happened it's just total
untrust
yeah i have put in my name but you knew
it was your property
yeah and would you recommend people do
that or do you think that is
stupid it depends it depends on your
family relationship
but some of the properties that you've
got in your name though i know nearly
all of them we've moved out there but
for instance
the one in wales to be honest i'd be
very happy if you stole it from me no
you wouldn't
i'd be very happy if russell stole
durham road oh yeah
because some of them weren't great no
but then others
have been fantastic so now i really
appreciate you coming on the show
um i know it's rare it feels weird me
interviewing you guys because normally
when i'm interviewing people i'm
interviewing people that i've helped
become financially free and property but
on this occasion especially the other
way around
because you guys help me
become financially free by firstly
believing in me as a kid
and just nurturing me with love and
complete belief and support even when
my school teachers probably didn't and
then also just practically
introducing me to the world um i mean
you and dad introduced me to
entrepreneurship but then tim kind of
introduced me to investment and business
but i'm just really grateful massively
massively grateful and i
shout you out at every crash course
um and it's really good to have you on
the show um
so did you know when i was at school
that i was going to be
a property entrepreneur or an
entrepreneur yeah yeah
i did i i said it was like having a mini
richard brunson living in the house
i remember saying that and that that's
the kind of thing is so funny
when you speak words over people
i think that it it comes true so you
saying that maybe that wasn't the case
at the time
maybe it wasn't like having a mini mini
richard branson but because
that's what you thought and that's what
you said
it manifested i don't know i can't
remember how old you were
but probably about 13 and
we've gone to a family party and it was
a karaoke probably 150 people massive
room and
people were getting up to sing and
everyone was ignoring them all at the
bar
you got up you did gangsters paradise
yeah everyone came away from the bar
everyone just stopped what they were
doing
like all the family couldn't believe it
and they just stood there
watching you about 13. and we were quite
stunned
at the time although you'd shown signs
of being
you've got something i think that was
the time for me when i thought wow
you know you absolutely stole the room
and everyone was just
and everyone was telling us afterwards
it was amazing it was amazing
and i think that was we've had a few
little things going through but that was
definitely a
monumental how does that link to
entrepreneurship though
it is um i think it's linked to the fact
the way you perform on stage
yeah you had that presence you took
control it captivated people
it's a kind of leadership um i remember
when i was about 16 and uh i can't
remember exactly where
where abouts what the stage was but i
just left school
and i think i just left working um
on dad's entertainment business i just
left which was horrible
um but i remember just having so much
like
you know i remember you described me as
a loose cannon yes
i don't know if you remember that but um
i mean
it's funny because i had opportunities
tim you you were in property you
refinanced and were buying properties
which caught my interest
how does that work and what's happening
um
do you think that i just i just think
for me for my kids i want to give them
opportunity i didn't have handouts you
know i didn't have people giving me
money
no one gave me money but i did have
opportunities
what do you think as parents because i
know a lot of people watching this
they might be uh parents or they might
be
parents one day how do you support your
kids
and even me asking you as a parent now
i've got two kids
i don't want ruby and luke to have
anything handed on a plate so i don't
want to give them money give them but at
the same time i want to give them
massive opportunities to succeed how
what's the best way
what would be the best advice that you'd
give a parent to help their kids
be as successful and happy as possible
you've got to be looking for their
giftings
every child's got giftings everyone's
got giftings and you make sure you
develop those giftings
and i saw giftings in you i saw
chieftains in russell and in tiffany
and you make sure those giftings are
brought out and you encourage them in
that
and i think also well there's so many
things
but you've just said you weren't handed
everything on a plate
yeah i remember when tiffany wanted a
hamster she was about eight
and it was gonna cost 40 quid but the
hamster in the cage and the food
weren't expensive i could have just
bought it for her but instead of saying
no
or just buying it i said well how can
you get that hamster
and within three days she had it
because she got a bargain she walked on
her own to the shop
got a bargain pages found a 10 pound
second-hand cage
phoned for it herself did jobs around
the house
everyone was like letting her clean the
room like you and everyone
for two quid and within about three days
she ran
grandad and said can you give me a lift
because i wouldn't give her a lift
because i said you've got to sort it
yeah
and so it was being completely
supportive of her
but it was also making her do the work
yeah and i think that is so important
because
like you're in your position now you
could easily accidentally spoil your
kids couldn't you
yeah and so could russell yeah with his
kids
and and for me i know i've i've said i'm
gonna make my kid pay taxes and
and things because that that for me is
is a is a biggest fear as a parent
it's just because because i had to work
so hard i'm not saying no one gave me
opportunities and no one
believed in me not at all but i had to
work absolutely
crazy hard to get financial independence
and to get to where i'm at
and um i've been saying with my students
if if you don't charge for education
people won't
value it in the same way with tiffany
with the hamster
if you don't work for something you just
take it for granted so
let me get a little bit it makes you
think outside the box instead of saying
expecting your mom to get you everything
or
instead of just being heard no can we
have this no
no you stop asking you stop questioning
you stop wanting things
yeah but if you're told well how
and you make them think creatively yeah
that's going to follow through into life
isn't it
yeah and and throwing the problem back
yeah saying well yeah yes you can
but you've got to find the money yeah
yeah
i think another thing is the family
works as a team
do you remember that time that tim
needed help to do up a property
and there was like russell anna you beth
tiff everyone was happy to go but you
had a paper round
so the whole family did your paper
around with you yeah yeah in order that
you were freed up to
yeah and i think we still do that as a
family don't we yeah
so we all work together when something's
needed we all
plug together yeah and i think that's
really key
i want to get a little bit of background
um your background as well tim
because um it's interesting because
growing up so sort of i i almost feel
like we i went from
middle class and i've not really i don't
know what you think about this
sort of middle class you know mom and
dad
dad's background from when i was a
gardener
prior to that background in sales you
were working as a mobile hairdresser
throughout most of my childhood we
lived a reasonably comfortable life kind
of standard
then you and dad mum split up when i was
seven
and then we had it pretty financially
pretty tight would you agree yeah you
know we were pretty skinned
um for for for a good few years and i
remember that
stage pretty pretty well um
and then you and tim got married and
tim's background is an accountant and he
was a little bit more not wealthy but
you know
lived a reasonably comfortable life and
then suddenly when i became a teenager
you know so i kind of feel like i've
experienced and seen different
know what it's like to have a bit of
money and be comfortable also
gone through stages in life where we
haven't got carpets on the floor because
we can't afford them and you're
i'm living with you and the kid and
siblings singing so it's really kind of
like all over the place
but in terms of like background um
and growing up what what what's your
background
if anyone's interested like what what
how did
so education business
festival shy i'll go first
my parents were teachers and they
sent me down the academic route but i'm
not academic
so there's a tension in that i got my a
levels
i didn't go to university my parents my
father was particularly annoyed that i
hadn't gone to university
but be that may i then went
trying to find employment um i'm colour
blind
and that prevented me getting into an
awful lot of careers i wanted to do
particularly the science
route which is well studied for a day
level
um so i ended up by accident
when i called it in the candidacy a job
that i
actually hated from day one but i stuck
it for 26 years
until i had enough then cared for
candidacy
pursued something i was more interested
in like interior design which seemed odd
because i was colorblind that's
another story and then i
went to this event where
one person was speaking about property i
was
i'm interested in property i didn't know
i could buy properties i thought he had
had
hard cash to buy under the property
didn't he give you a mortgage
and i was intrigued and i came back
and said to sue so about going to
property investing and i thought she'd
say no and she said yeah why not
and that's a nutshell in property
investing
and when you started doing that i was at
school sniffing around
interested like what's this what what
you know taking a massive interest and
that's something actually that
growing up we always did we always
talked about these businesses everything
together
yeah we talked about we did everything
together and we also talked about
business and money
and it wasn't taboo ever to talk about
money was it no
so when tim started getting into
property i would be picking his brain
how much you invest in how are you doing
it you're refinancing what does that
mean
and that was when i first had my eyes
opened
to to property and i remember just
thinking
and people probably know my my story but
i remember thinking at the time
dad was lining me up to go and work for
him
and now i'm getting this whiff of oh
property investment tim seems really
excited tim's smart i
you know i know when when he first got
married minty might have not been best
friends to begin with
but but but i always respected tim as a
as
with his financial numbers and stuff
because he's an accountant and
he definitely knew more about money than
anyone any of my school teachers
although ironically you were also my
school teacher correct
yes just just just phil phil fill anyone
in
hell well when i finished an accountancy
and i was going to interior design
um your headmaster got
with that i was free and said well i
come and help out at the school
uh on the admin side and i thought me i
could probably do that
so i came in to help on the up inside
yeah
but your head must have been your
headmaster i thought oh i
can use tim to do some careers advice
with some of the children
so i ended up teaching on careers advice
yeah so so
so i knew you when i first found out
you were mr grey to me when when
you you first got engaged and it was
crazy weird
so it was a little bit awkward
potentially from from my part and of
course still having a great relationship
with
my dad ethan and he taught me a lot
about business and entrepreneurship as
well so
you know but but but i was torn wanted
to get into property and
and do what you were doing because you
could see how excited you were with it
um you introduced me to simon zushier
yeah
i remember going down to a pin meeting
with you i don't know if
even you remember in birmingham you you
took me to birmingham pin meeting
do you remember fairly record very
reckless
yeah yeah and you know that was
that was how i got introduced to
property and
we traveled together yeah our trip to
blackpool
yeah where you drove yes my car i drove
after you'd only got your provisional
license for two weeks
yeah just turned 17 and
i think that i think at the time
you tim were doing no money down deals
i.e buy refurbished not even refurbished
then buy with finance
yeah and correct me if i'm wrong but
kind of how
the setup was because it was a no money
down deal and you tell me from because
we haven't
actually spoke with this for years this
is how i remember it so
with all the training that was going
around at the time on on the masterminds
and different things and i was very much
getting myself out there
chatting to people i was in with the
builders in birmingham i was like i even
when did i work on the building site do
you want to do some work on the building
site
after you did your plastering my
plastering crash course
sometimes about
so i was i was desperate to become
valuable
as far as i was coming i'm just thinking
my stepdad
is i knew together but i know it was
tim's yeah
you know thing that he was but you were
doing it together but is is
buying some properties he's doing it
in a creative way which sounds awesome
but i don't understand
i gotta get in on this so my in on this
is how can i be valuable to tim
yeah and how can i be valuable to
the builders and and and the property
trainers and anyone and everyone that
anyone that's in property
how can i be valuable to them because i
know if i just get their crumbs
i got nothing i can't get a mortgage
i've got zero property backgrounds i've
got
literally nothing going for me but if i
can be valuable
yeah even if it's a case of taking those
awkward phone calls of the tenants that
that tim or whoever might just be like
oh i've got a kick out of 10. i'll do it
you know i'll i'll go and have that
awkward conversation
if i can be valuable to
property investors that was kind of my
in
and you did so many different things and
you know like remember when we did at
maryvell road you were only 18 then
yeah and you plastered that wall yeah
but but i would do anything yeah um i
did it i was plastering to try and make
a bit of money
but on the property side i wasn't trying
to work i wasn't trying to
work for money i was doing a bit of
plastering and i was doing a little bit
of this a little bit
i was doing utility warehouse so i was
doing things to make money but i was
i was trying to be valuable to people
thinking in my head in the long run if
i'm
valuable to people then then i'm gonna
i'm gonna get some crumbs and and but
you you're good at it i i still
i still remember to this day when i got
my
wolverhampton hmos and i was setting
them all up i was there doing work on
the properties
you know the brand new builds there's no
referral it was just a case of getting
things ready
and you're showing prospective tenants
around
and the way you're doing it was they
thought you owned the property
and they just treated me as if well he
just worked me down there
i was going to say that just i didn't
yeah yeah because because i was at the
same time still i was i was studying jim
rohn
i was studying personal development
sales so the way i'd carry myself i'd
dress well i was very very young
but people would think that but i also
remember i thought you were going to say
um like i'd sit on my hands and knees
10 hour days with you every day flat
packing oh yeah yeah
now i'm not thinking what what am i
getting paid for this
that to me what i knew was that would be
a poor
person's attitude yeah what am i getting
paid for this i don't care i'm getting
paid for it
i'm just glad that tim's spending time
with me
and i'm able to talk to him about
property education isn't it exactly and
and what how i remember it was gonna say
is at the time because
when you could find a property that was
below market value
and you could buy it and you could
refinance it and because you had the
connections
with um the bridging companies and stuff
from the mastermind groups
the sort of setup as i remember it was
if we all just work together me you and
mom
collectively to try and find these
freaking deals
it doesn't matter who finds the deal it
doesn't matter who views the deal it
doesn't matter who's been doing flatback
news
we're working together and we're out
absolutely like crazy trying to find
deals we're negotiating we're driving
around the country
trying to find deals and the kind of
deal was
that if i'm really helping and i'm
bringing deals to the table and
then then i would have every time you
got nine i'd get one
is that exactly i don't remember that do
you mean
i don't remember that don't remember
that precisely but you maybe i'm not it
was like a one in ten
you remember that oh really oh that was
definitely what it was okay
that was definitely i don't think i
cared i think it was just like we're all
working it was kind of like that but the
thing is it's almost like look
right tim's got a little money yeah from
from refinancing
station mode right the house that you
lived in because
because you old school prior to that
work hard
work in a job you hate save up money put
it in the bank pay the mortgage off
and that's where you've got to so you're
like maybe 40 50 now 50 years old
i think i pay mortgage off from about 30
35 years old right got married when you
were 47.
so now you've been made a few years so
you're like early 50s with your mortgage
paid off
refinance you want to get this money to
to work put it in put it out put it and
pull it out but then
my attitude is well if i can find you
deals that you can do the
pull it and put it out and we'll then
then if i'm finding the deals then
then you'll be my guarantor host
actually
have it in your name but earmark it for
me and hold it for me until i'm at
an age where where i can kind of
transfer it so we're just working crazy
finding deals
and my first property was mover road
yeah correct
which was actually i think
it was the week before or two weeks
prior to my 80th birthday
just before your 18th yeah so it's
technically 17
when it completed and that was a blast
oh my goodness the feeling
of being like i own a house
to me
growing up like a year before i was
doing paper rounds
you know it was really really really
really weird
and cool yeah but i felt like by the
time i got that property to be fair i've
been working my tits off
for almost 30 years well maybe but but
specifically on property for a year
working like crazy seeing tim buying
houses
and helping tim and and stuff so that
was the first property
and we
did that as hmo
i was thinking then time that didn't
make sense because i remember at bible
college but that was to be much later
when the property was having a refurb
i don't remember we did a refurb on it
me and you initially yeah remember to
bang that fireplace out plastic
we did that to start you off yes to get
that property up and running because it
was
not in terrible condition it was a bit
run down the kitchen was a bit naff
yes yeah and then what happened was a
few years later
you did the kitchen didn't you did the
kitchen and we went around and decorated
it that's when we were at bible college
ah okay that makes sense now so that
property
the refurb we did ourselves that was
pretty much me and you single-handed
respect dream team dream team and
that refurb cost us next to nothing i
don't know how much hundreds of pounds
probably
um plastered it painted it
put tents in it rented out room by room
and do you remember how much rent i got
is it 1300 about 350 a room about 1400
about 1400. still got the house today
it's almost doubled in value now in
birmingham that was my very first house
and after that i did what did you want
to do because i didn't buy any houses
after that for a little while
come with the time school i bought the
wolverhampton properties then
which i was managing for free yeah and
then we ended up getting what we call
the derrick properties
talk to me about the derek crouches
oh my goodness the dairy properties
the derrick properties were very
interesting
because why did we even get into that
what happened
because what had happened was you
couldn't do that back-to-back
remortgaging
yeah but morgan especially gone bump so
you couldn't do that yeah
when we did maryvale we had
i stood to this date on the house and i
got the mortgage but i still don't know
how that actually deal was done
um because that was right in the
knickers
um thank god i wouldn't have got my
first house
i bought the jmi road properties with
someone who did effectively
he bought them and saw them back to me
same day but that was just we did that
just a nick of time before that
was capped couldn't do that then we're
stuck for harry do no di
money in deal and somehow i came across
derrick
and uh the his deal was slightly
different
and we we paid that i think
wasn't it two thousand pound fee i think
it was that's all the money put in
and they were able to they did
especially a joint venture
yeah vendors that were selling it how
does it how does the derek deals work
because
i'll tell you something at the time i
just remember being
talking to derek on the phone you
introduced me to derek and
it was a case of you pay a 2 000 3 000
down payment and then you have a house
which is half owned by
the current owner but you own half the
house rent it out
all good and then down the line you can
either buy them or they buy you out
and but i'm just thinking like geez if i
can put down
two or three thousand pounds i can make
that in plastering i can make that in
letting getting little fees or i can
bang that on a i did bang that on a
credit card when we were on holiday yeah
i did you went into the lloyd's bank
yeah
i remember it yeah and i got my credit
card and i went do you remember what
happened i remember you going into the
lawyers bank and we were all sat outside
with the dog waiting and i wanted to get
the house yes
i was like anything to get a house i
must have been 19
were they probably i don't think i
bought any houses when i was 18. i think
i bought
maryville road just before turning 18
and then 18 years old i was working my
ass off trying to desperately but i
actually think
19 was when the grandma leads
the deal i bought that little house in
block switch
it's the did the lease option agreement
in block switch
okay very similar and then the derick
properties but that that sort of
year was when i started like like
properties
not all great prices but that was kind
of like when quite a few came in
i think the thing was that we had that
big crash didn't we in 2008
yeah so everything changed and a lot of
people got out of investing
but what we were all trying to do was
find a new
way it's like when you come to a dead
end and you've got to get
go back and look for some other routes
it's about being fluid and
that's always the case and so we were
looking for another route we found the
derrick route and thought this is it
yeah but then you know
tim got into refurbs and you got into
hmos and that and
you just have to keep finding a new
route when one route closes
yeah you have to look and be creative
don't you so the derrick's deal then
what was what was what was the crap with
that tim
i can't remember how the deal was done
to get it as a nominee in deal
um i'd need more time to think that
through again
but basically the vendor sells property
and then has a share they put that money
back into the deal
and they have a share in the equity of
the property and they have that
for as long as they want but if they can
they can pull out that money at any time
um and in the first 10 years there's a
sliding scale
as to how much money they can pull out
some weird it's a very weird agreement
i've never heard seen or heard i bought
a couple
from derek you bought a few from derek
um one of mine is the bane of my life
and it's
owned in russell's name and that's on
durham road because a lot of my
properties
this time i was putting them in
different people's names and stuff um
russell bought that one and to be honest
i genuinely
at the time i was thinking do i need a
contract russell
if russell screws me over but i thought
he's not gonna do that he's my brother
it's all good
but now all i could screw where's the
contract yeah i could screw rustler by
letting him have the house
because it's such a bad house the bbc
did a whole documentary about that house
pretty much i was on the week the
landlords moved in and
they went through my whole portfolio i
can't believe i even trusted them enough
to be like yeah go like
now knowing what i know about the bbc
but they went through all my properties
spoke to all my tenants picked the worst
house
which was that one and i had to live in
it for for a week and it was it was fun
but that was a crazy house
i mean at this time what what would you
say
the biggest sort of struggles lessons
things because
you know you just start buying houses
and and things were going like then the
crash came
everyone's at the time was saying i mean
from what i remember
buy till it's dead property prices are
going to absolutely crash
it's a bad time to buy get out get out
get out
all the property trainers even were
running around like headless chickens
not knowing what to say or what to teach
they didn't know what to teach because
all their strategies
yeah finished i'm thinking my goodness
like i don't know what to do as far as i
was concerned i kind of think i have
very little to lose
i'm still living at home yeah i've got a
nice little bit of an income coming in
from my little small property portfolio
i've got a link
coming from which to be fair for me
living at home
like i was getting paid more than my
school friends that thought i was crazy
going into property
so i'm doing okay and i just wanted more
houses yeah
that was all i wanted but what what kind
of got you through
that time and what happened and what
sort of character traits do you think
that you need to get through
a recession hmm dog with a burn to be
honest at the very beginning it was
really hard the first
massive problem we had before
before you got into it wasn't it with
kohl's hill
oh yeah first massive problem we had
was this humongous we bit off a massive
project this great big
old listed build didn't know anything
about listed buildings
we were completely in at the deep end
where did you find that property and who
recommended it at the time i was looking
for
properties where i could get a planning
game so i was filming property it could
be converted into something flats
get the planning gain and i'm gonna pass
it on to a builder that's that was my
strategy at the time
and obviously made that known to a few
estate agents and one day i got a phone
call from a state agent we've got
property he might be interested in
um it's got planning permission et
cetera to be converted into flats you're
interested and i said no i'm not
interested
well they pressured me a bit and i
thought go on there i'll come and look
at it
look around the property i thought hang
on there's still some fat in the game
here
i could probably even the planning game
i can still make money
out of the build so i then decided yeah
i'm gonna
i'm gonna buy it and i may i did that
with a totally no money in deal that was
a straightforward hundred nobody down
deal
down here there was there was it was a
straightforward hundred percent
finance yeah uh by contact
networking um but that did cause a few
headaches
i remember although i wasn't involved i
was at school i was still involved in
the conversations and remember tim
coming home and
talking about and to be honest that
would have probably put a lot of people
off
to me that was like a black cloud
following you everywhere you went
yeah but after that you had uh
i mean i hope you don't mind me saying
but you ended up having to go to court
with the builders
oh yes and it was rough it was very
rough
very very rough we missed a really great
holiday over it yeah
because we had to be around to sign
these things and you won in court
we did but at the time that whole thing
was like a black cloud
following me around that's how i felt
yeah
but since then and we ended up
good out of that it worked yeah and
since then i've
and we've never worried about money yeah
so at that time i worried what if we
lose our house what if this happens
i remember when tim used to always say
if this doesn't come off now we're gonna
go under yeah that was the big thing
we're gonna go under we're gonna go
under
but ever since that we haven't worried
about money and you've never gone under
we've never gone under but i think we
did a fundamental
wrong thing there yeah i think we took
on a project
that was capable of making us go under
and i think that really we should have
started with something a bit more
smaller do you know what's so
interesting about that i mean my
uh opinion on this is i always say to
people
when you get started and you do your
first deal you're gonna
make mistakes you're gonna make mistakes
so
you're better off to start small however
a big deal and a small deal take the
exact same amount of effort
so me now i'd much rather do a much
bigger deal
because it's more money it's less effort
it's less hassle i don't want to do it
or deals
so it's almost a case of start small but
then every time you do a deal i think go
bigger and bigger and bigger
and build up to the big deals or find
somebody that you can joint venture with
who you can trust but you know you took
on a massive project
but we took on something that could
bankrupt us yeah
and i wouldn't recommend that i would
take on something that's risk yes i'm
not saying don't be risk
don't take any risk but make it so that
if it
does go pear shaped you have a safety
net and we didn't really did we
but then no one could have predicted the
2008 crash
and we were just the problem was we just
finished the refurb
and then we couldn't sell them and they
were dropping in value by the day
yeah so you know that was a very sticky
situation but since then
i've not worried about money at all and
i think that's good
you've not worried because you've not
had to because you've had lots of money
or is it a
mental mental you just said i'm not
going to worry about it correct
yeah but then to be fair as well i don't
think until that project
prior to that growing up i know that we
sometimes had
nothing and we were skinned but you
never worried about money it's not part
of my dna
no you've never worried about me i've
never and i think that was an exception
it was an exception so and also um
like tim had always had a reasonably
reasonable paid job
and you hope you hope i'm not saying
anything
but you you'd know what it's like to
have no money at all and it's fine
and not know where your next thing is
going to come from or next whereas tim
had always had a job and a bit of
security so for tim maybe be in a
situation where it's like
this could make us go under it's quite a
big deal for him big deal for tim
and i think am i right tim yeah because
accountants have a
they expect to be to be good with money
yeah during the accountant
and i think accountants are trained to
be risk averse
yeah and i had to go through that mental
change hang on i need to take some risks
somewhere on the line calculated risks
but i know my mindset is very different
from me
i haven't got a mindset of any cancer
anymore i can still play with numbers
but mindset is not an accountant's
mindset it has changed
now around about 2011 2012 i think 2011
you had a reasonable healthy portfolio
that basically enabled you to be
full-time in property or
financially free if you want to call it
that but basically had an income coming
in from your rents which covered
an average sort of salary is that fair
to say yeah
and then throughout the years of bible
college because we went to barber
college together
yeah because i was in a similar boat i
had again i wasn't really wealthy
but i had a little healthy portfolio
that also has given me
a nice little income not massive but was
probably
about the same or more than an average
salary so i was
i was i was okay as well financially so
that we're all at that sort of boat
where we're like right cool you've got
over that stupid project with goals
got a nice little healthy portfolio i've
got another healthy portfolio that i've
built up
um and then 2011 went to bible college
we knew it's bubble code we tried to get
tim to go but tim wasn't interested
and we spent three years at barber
college and then after bible college and
during because during barbell college
i didn't know about you but i wasn't i
wasn't really growing my portfolio big
time i wasn't
i wasn't even thinking about property i
mean i was just letting my properties
tick over and some of them went up in
value a little bit and
you know fine i was i was maybe a little
bit but i wasn't
pushing i wasn't trying to raise finance
and grow and i
deal packaging i was just letting it
sort of tick and i was focusing
on because bible college was intense um
what kind of happened property wise
after that
um after that sort of era yeah because
because i remember at bible college
thinking
i don't even know if i want to be a
businessman
at the time i was trying to find out my
purpose in life
and my calling and my you know what
what's god put me on this earth for
i want to figure out why i'm here and i
was honestly i was single
i was honestly open for absolutely
anything i would have moved to africa
um and and and set up a church plant
i would have like and we actually did we
moved
to limo as a family yeah
so while i i was at bible college and
i was doing well it was full time wasn't
it really bible college yeah but it was
it was
three days two days and then you had to
do a mission on top yeah so three days a
week we had to travel to birmingham
and we had to spend it was three full
days that was tuesday wednesday thursday
and then monday friday we'd do mission
and we'd we'd and we had dissertations
and homework yes
it was kind of i mean yeah it was full
time not i was doing a lot on top but it
was
yeah yeah so when we went to lee moore
i was running four youth clubs
yep so i used to come home from bible
college at four
no about five and then at six i've got
to
run a youth club and i was doing the
talks everyone
at that point so i'd like got to eat my
tea
ten minutes to decide what i was going
to teach them that night
and then i'd get home at nine o'clock we
go and pick them all up in the bus
and we did that four times a week so
it was so full-on and
we didn't really do much property then
did we we ticked over what we've got
same as me kind of yeah and then when
that was over because it was like a
three-year thing
we bought that property in market
drayton
yeah we bought that at auction yeah
which was
similar to the coal seal one it great
big old
yeah in a conservation area and how did
you finance that one
how do we find that one we had money
we had some money and we borrowed
borrowed
jb didn't we yeah yeah we borrowed some
money for the do it yeah
so you so you bought it for how much 120
120 120 and then you spent how much on
the refurb
on crumbs i remember now i'm 30 for the
time being i can't remember that he
bought it for 120 he's been about 30 on
it which is 150 in and then how much did
you refinance it that
i voted for 210 and
what 75 percent of that i think it was
great so that's like uh
all the money out really yeah so it's
like a buy refurbished financing
nearly all of your money out that's it
that's a nice little deal
and what about now are you are you doing
like
you know oh great like when i left bible
college
i mean i i i just went crazy didn't i
on on the property side of things and i
think for me
i got to the point i went i started
barbara college when i was 20. i think
i've been about 20 years old
had a little nice little portfolio great
technically was financially free
but at the time i wouldn't have gone
wrong saying i remember tim even a youth
group saying
um you know samuel i don't know if you
remember this tim but we were at the
um lee moore in one of the little youth
centers
and you were giving a talk and you were
teaching the kids about money
and you were telling them you know about
teaching them about money and management
and
being a good steward and being able to
add value and all that and then you said
samuel i was like 19 maybe 20. i was
about 20 years old
and you said samuel um he's 20 and
he won't ever have to work again if he
doesn't want to because of his
properties i don't remember that do you
not remember that do you remember that
my comment was saying that yeah
it did but you used to do talks and i
just sort of remember thinking like
i guess technically it's true but i
didn't at the time
that's not that wasn't where i was at oh
i was just thinking
i'm just getting kind of started yeah i
was hungry for life i was hungry for
business
during bible college my property
business ticked over yeah
it ticked over i might have bought a
couple houses but
i can't remember um wasn't your main
focus no i think i did buy a couple
two or three little houses but that
would have only been maybe a property
went up a little bit or pushed it and
refinanced it might bought a couple
houses but then when i left barber
college when i would have been 22
and that was when i i'd written my book
do the possible and and i i decided that
i
i was gonna go hard in business
and i was literally packaging and
selling deals like great do you remember
my deal packaging business was blowing
up
[Music]
do you remember that blowing up what did
you think when i started selling that
many deals
i know i thought it was strange he was
selling these properties that he found
on the right move and i thought
he can't do that yeah i remember you i
remember you calling me out on it and
let me say but then where did you buy
your properties from your colleagues
as you say everyone starts off on right
move then they want all the property
training say well i know
you've got to go this way leafleting do
this this they end up still going back
to right
because that's where most of the
properties are anyway yeah it's just
hard work finding
the rest of them but the thing is though
yes the properties that i were looking
at on right move
but there were still good deals and i
would
very hard to to negotiate and to find
deals
and and that is what made me a
millionaire i think the thing
is with you is that
you actually you're like come on
i'm gonna hold your hand and make you do
it yeah so
your kind of training isn't just
teaching someone and then letting them
go
yeah you almost get them under your wing
yeah and you're talking now just so
someone what doesn't watch this and go i
came to the crash course and that didn't
happen
you're talking about when i set up milo
went high yeah and i was
selling deals i wasn't just selling it
at
yeah that might have been i might have
they weren't all about this but a lot of
them were with estate agents some of
them are off market
some of them were on market some of them
were direct divided but a lot of them
were
with ages i can remember a lot of the
people were like
like it's like you're on a high diving
board and you won't jump in yes
and the people were there going i don't
really want to do property but i'm a
teacher and you just grabbed the hand
and went come on and gave them that
courage yeah and i used to go and i used
to spend a day with them i'd take them
around the area
i'd hold their hand through the process
and i wouldn't just sort of
go oh there there's a deal that is on
within the stage and good luck wash my
hands
no i would i would charge them a fee and
and often
in the early days it would be like two
thousand pounds i want a thousand pound
up front and then i'll take another
thousand off you when you complete
and in the meantime i'll hold your hand
so i was offering a lot of
value um that is when i did begin
getting my first few haters
because some of the deals might fall out
of bed it's kind of inevitable
and then people would um you know and of
course i'd put that right and i'd refund
them or whatever
but but when you start selling that
amount of deals i mean geez i sold over
i sold over 200 deals in the space of
about two years
yeah and i mean you do the math i made a
lot of money in that put that into
property mostly i was also subsidizing
training kings yeah uh christian
business networks i was using i was
giving i was going back and forth to
africa a lot and i was living life to
the fullest and i was using the money
well but you know that was when my
property business went from small
you know blue because i was using the
money to reinvest yeah and i remember
you tim you you you lost track with what
i was buying and yeah
because before that point every time i
buy a property like a big deal
yeah tim do you want to come and have a
look and i bought this house and look at
this
was that point i was just buying houses
left right and center
like what did you do last week i bought
a house and i sold six
that was my conversation over a haircut
what yeah what while we'd meet
um and and you were really involved in
the mission and the work with the street
kids yeah
church plans um and
i don't think you guys and i might be
totally wrong now
but you probably didn't want to put the
same
like energy and aggression
into building a business then i did i
don't like selling deals
yeah because i know
from our experience there's always
a problem so i'd find a deal for us
like rowley street which was around that
time yeah
beautiful six-bed hmo just bought it
there's a dump problem and dry rot now
we just take it on the chin
yeah five grand so what that's
business that's life that's how it works
or you're doing a road property
oh geez yeah when you're selling deals
i don't like that because then they come
back to me but do you not do not think
though i agree with you
that's about setting expectations and
saying
listen this is i think so but i think
we like doing what we do if you're a
deal seller
yeah you want to say it wasn't something
i wanted you you never wanted to do any
of that no
it's not it's not my bad i need i agree
you make money out of it but it's not
i'm happy to take the money and take and
take the headache yeah
i'm happy and yes it comes with
headaches i remember when i was
um driving around california newly
married to amanda like maybe 2016
and i got people on the phone to me you
know oh samuel
my room's not renting and this and that
and it it comes with problems
when you're packaging and selling that
many deals but
it's also you want to be you want to you
want to be
successful in business you want to scale
a business you want to become a
millionaire
you're going to have to have a lot of
crap you do
you can't have any business enough well
we have that but in a different way yeah
and it's like you could say oh you buy a
list of buildings you've got to go
through all that
but that's sort of like crap that we
don't mind yeah and you've all got your
own
every every strategy comes with crap
doesn't exactly have your own
and it depends on where you're at see i
teach rent to rent
i teach deal packaging i teach lease
option agreements i teach
hmos i teach and they've all got their
pros and they've all got their cons
right you know and depending on what
kind of you might aren't prepared to
take on that con you know deal packaging
you've got to deal with investors and
you've got sale you've got i don't want
to do that
but then it's oh i want to do um
conversions
like barn conversions oh well you got to
deal with planning
officers and this i don't want to deal
with that so i think depending on
how much money you've got how much time
you've got like when i when i started
out and i was 17 i had no money i had
nothing going for me
apart from courage basically you know i
was happy to take on anything on the
chin as long as i was to get myself a
house yeah so i think it really just
depends on where you're at
yeah and what your giftings are yeah
because you could go into deal sourcing
and not be able to find it you haven't
got that kind of a mind
so it is a case of there's so many
niches in property
but it's a case of finding which one you
want to go back it's doing what you
enjoy doing
yeah i think i thought you'd probably
know who said this but everyone says
about being success what does this
success mean yeah it is doing what you
want to do
yeah and it's a case of doing you know i
like doing i like it hands-on in
building and
but that's not what you taught by all
the professionals and trainers they say
you don't make money that way but that's
what i love doing i remember
simon zush's course he
on properties said this what you want
out of life
another woman next to me was writing
reams and reams and reams
i was i think the top of my list was do
a barn conversion
yeah that's what i'm going to do i'm now
doing that
yeah that's your niche you've done rent
to rent
yeah you've done hmos you've still got
hmos they're so
you're making decent money from your
hmos you've done
most of the strategies or touched on
them or seen me do them
and you've done conversions and now
you're doing your thing you found your
niche you're living where you want to
live
yeah um what do you think of training of
property training because
you've done property training i know
you've done a lot of property training
like to the point where tim is a little
bit of a course junkie i would say i
don't know what you think mum
i wouldn't say that i need to say that
well you do go on a lot of courses
courses
um some of them have not been beneficial
to me
yeah some have um and not just property
courses you just
did a course as well but and you do a
lot of networking and yeah i've done as
much now but i have done a lot
but you you used to do a lot for
networking and
all that i don't know if you did bni
you're not sure what you're working
you're using learning networking i mean
and you've done a lot of courses we used
to do courses together yeah
and it was so funny because when we'd
gone courses together
we used to sometimes be split between
was this amazing or was this
really really crap didn't we what was
that about
um well
and we changed our mind i love that
trainer and then the next day i'd be
like i hate him
that's probably what people feel about
me sometimes though but i mean
what was what was your experience of
going on training courses and stuff
because sometimes it was great and
sometimes it sucked but i always
loved them yeah did you at the time yeah
but then sometimes they weren't really
that helpful
go on um just trying to think i think
whilst you think i think some of the
training you go of course you it's a
brilliant course
until you actually go to do it yeah i
think hang on they haven't told us that
they haven't told us that yeah yeah yeah
that's the bit i really need to know
so like you go on a i don't know
course on essay and then you go to do it
and you think oh yeah i don't do you
think that there's an element because
because i think that's always going to
happen to a point
i'm a trainer i run the biggest property
training company in the uk
and i would like to think that that's
not the case i mean you've seen our
training and stuff for natural and it's
very very thorough
um but to a point it's like when you
when you
you know when they say when you pass
your driving test that's when you really
learn to drive yeah
there's only so much that you can learn
while not doing something that's right
and until you actually do it and get
stuck and go
oh man i'm stuck and then you've got to
almost
find someone to ask or figure it or but
you can't learn
everything what you can do is you can
learn the outline and the steps but
there's going to be a little bit of
figuring out as you go along perhaps do
you think i think
some people think that going on a course
is a bit like fairy dust yeah so
they're going to pay to grand tangrand
whatever it is
and that's going to ensure that they'll
be successful yeah it's good that's
going to be their magic wand yeah it's a
fairy dust
yeah and i don't think it is
um it's like going to weight watchers
and expecting to lose weight
they'll give you the skills joining a
gym yeah
and getting a personal trainer and
having a dietitian give you a plan
and then going oh in that case i've paid
for it i'm gonna just get slimming on
another six-pack it's like no no
that's the tools that's the support
that's the resources but you have to
actually do it yeah yeah definitely
that's so true
and i think that the other thing is that
um
if you there's big money in property
isn't there yep
massive money yep so if you learn
something
that's going to change the course of
your
property business yep you can't really
put a value on that
like i remember when we used to save up
to buy properties didn't we so we used
to
work and work and work save and save and
save and then with that money
buy say a hmo and then we had to wait
ages to buy the next thing
yep and then we'd learn say
use other people's money suddenly oh
that's sped it up a bit now yeah
so how can you put a value on that
you've got to go back
track and go because knowledge is it's
like a spider's web
you'll learn this and put that with that
and this with this and it forms a
foundation and a building block
you can go on a course you've got to put
the effort in as well yeah
and the two together is what
helps you grow yeah i grow do you think
you've got to i was thinking this when i
went on my first property course
i've gone with the mindset i'm going to
do property i just don't know how to do
it
so i was i was already on a journey and
i'm getting
so i went off i remember talking to the
mortgage broker he says
cool i'm glad to see someone take the
action as a result of a course i said
well yeah
i've done paid 500 pounds to do nothing
with it
yeah um and that was very good of course
other courses have been on i thought
should i do that shan't i and because
you haven't got mine i'm definitely
gonna do it
you don't do it so it's all down to
mindset and get on and
doing it i um you
were at my very first property investors
crash course correct um
how much of you in total paid would you
say on
property training courses now i know
you've not paid for any of my property
training courses
and to do so it'll be somewhat ironic
because you introduced me to property in
the first place
uh you've been at my first crash course
but how much would you say
you guys have spent on property training
courses
in the last 15 years or however long
you've been in property
i don't know i've done i had after
tottenham oh but it's just
yeah it's about it okay um what i was
going to say is
did you know what that i remember going
on a lease option course
when i was probably 18. at that time and
it's like
what are we gonna do what's new you went
as well i did
and i remember thinking um i think we
paid about 500 each
and then it was called the lease option
whatever ultimate
no no then there was a then there was a
two grand at the ultimate which is kind
of
like not really much better and it was
like then there was the next five grand
and it was just like oh my goodness
however as annoying as it was at the
time
and i've always really not wanted to
stay away from any of that business if i
sell someone a course on these options
guess what they're going to get i can
course on these options guess what
they're not going to get
and upsell to a an advanced lease option
course like
that's just totally you know we don't do
that at all
um but to be fair i did then go and get
a lease option
yeah some time after which actually has
made me
probably about 60 grand
since if you take into account capital
appreciation and rent
so okay all right i spent a few grand
but actually do you not admit it's
really hard isn't it because you know i
think
go on i think property courses
are a bit like properties so
if you judged
whether a property was good or not by
your durham road
you'd say it was rubbish wouldn't you
yeah so you can buy
if you get a portfolio of 10 properties
are they making you money overall you're
going to have the odd one that's not
very good
you're going to have the odd one that's
absolutely brilliant yeah
i think that's what's happened to us
with courses like some courses
have been brilliant some mentoring has
been brilliant others
not so good but if you say overall are
you glad you did it
well then yeah yeah because you've had
those good ones yeah but do you really
think that people i guess that's why i
started training in a way but you really
think people should
therefore just go and do 10 different
courses and pay a load of money and just
say well some are going to be good and
i'm going to be back i think they should
have the right attitude to courses yeah
so if we buy a property and it's not
that great you just think
move on and so if you go on a course and
you think
i didn't learn i've gone on loads of
courses and thought i haven't learned
that much off that
i don't think anything i i would be
paying though if my students had that
attitude
um and were just like yeah i didn't
really know that much but it's all right
you know no big deal
like i would be personally i'd be really
good if that happened
but it's a good attitude i guess it's
like taking
a responsibility i guess isn't it i'd
say it's a moving forward attitude
yeah okay that's happened now let's go
forward
yeah yeah um what do you do you watch my
youtube videos ever
yeah yeah not all of them i know i do
one day
out of interest how often do you think
you watch a youtube video i watch them
when you
tell me to mommy get a little bit oh
yeah if i just ping it over here
like watch this one always watch it you
always watch them then what about
youtube
it's difficult to say on average i'd say
once
once a fortnight probably okay okay um
but
it depends on on the title
of the yeah really
yeah yeah
i'll watch that one yeah um
[Music]
others i'll see oh yes i'll follow that
one because i i don't wanna
generally because it's what it is but
it's a title that grabs you
yeah oh i intrigued me let's see
um have i changed from being a 17 year
old
working class kid to being of worth over
10 million pounds
personality two kids yeah no
pretty similar yeah what do you think
tim you went through a phase where you
changed
and you're back there i think it was
when you're back down to selling deals
when i was sorry when you're selling
deals yeah you first started to make a
lot of money
i remember had did he talk to you at the
time yeah i thought
you've changed yeah and we i
talked about it didn't we but you've
you've bounced back to
what you are now yeah yeah i agree with
that
you talked to me about talk to me about
that little era because that was
interesting
you were a kind of a focused
zoning out everything except work
yeah and i think i think you're more fun
than that really
yeah i think you've got more of a
work-life balance now
yeah you used to always be life and soul
of the party
yeah during that phase oh
someone was over there he hasn't seen
the world in the corner you weren't life
laughing sort of the party
yeah even new year's eve was just yeah
but now
you're back tomorrow i have to accept
that i have to accept that and say that
that is i'll stand by that i'll say yes
and i think that
um you know to to get
to to that point yeah i feel like i had
to almost be a bit of a ball
no that's fine and if i hadn't have done
that if i'd have been
all right cool work life balance i
probably
it'll take me another 15 years to get to
janetta man
i think now looking back it just seems
like a little blip
but at the time he was like what's going
on yeah
yeah has he changed forever is he going
to be a big bore another
area that i think maybe i went through a
little blip because we we
we've always been really really close
haven't we really growing up
you know and then probably after when i
went really hard
on the property side and started scaling
and growing and packaging deals and i
was
doing training kings and then like and
as my business started taking off i
started employing lots of stuff and i
suddenly had a responsibility to that
and i've
now got married and i got i number one
might have changed because i might have
been
totally just focused yeah secondly
i might have changed because i um
maybe too extreme went to the point of
you know you know
when you start saying things like oh i'm
not gonna
wash my car because i could pay someone
else to do it yeah right which is just
reasonable
but then you start taking that to the
nth degree you know
i'm not gonna do anything yeah because i
can pay someone to do it and
and then it's it's like well actually
what you know
every time i meet someone it has to be
an agenda and a reason otherwise it's a
waste of time yeah
i kind of maybe was a little bit there a
little bit there but it's just like
do you want to meet up and hang out and
have a barbecue well
no because i've got stuff to do and i'm
busy
and suddenly you lose um you lose
perspective why you got into business in
the first place a little bit
i think looking back it's completely
natural
what happened i also think that
it is part of your nature to have so
much drive and you really needed that
push to get you where you were
to get you where you are um but i think
it's something that i wouldn't want you
to be like forever
yeah i'm glad it was just a phase and
what what do you make of how big
training businesses have gone it's just
amazing
because it has gone just
it's just amazing amazing
did it ever did did it ever get to a
point where you
kind of just realized oh wow actually
quite
was there a room or i'd say well
it was like going back to your original
question
um it's just watching something happen
isn't it
yeah and then you suddenly think um
this is quite extraordinary
yeah because together as a three and as
a family and as a
we got to a pretty extraordinary place
really
just in the fact that having having a
property million pound property
portfolio and
being financially free and being able to
to start doing charity works and things
like that at 21. like that's kind of a
big deal
but then how far the business has gone
going back to how you've changed as well
yeah is that you've already alluded to
the fact that we did everything together
yeah family really close bible college
together missions together
everything even with the extended family
like you know with russell
and we were very very very close and
you have already alluded to you used to
pick tim's brain
i can remember a point thinking i don't
feel any use to samuel anymore
i don't feel that i can give him it i
don't mean i've got anything more to
offer because
you're now going to these mentors and
you're earning this money and you're
doing these deals
and for a phase
i felt a bit redundant as a mom do you
get that
i think so yeah like it didn't bother me
i was pleased for you yeah but you know
you didn't even need to ring up and say
how long do i put the beans in the
microwave
you know because i got a why it had
suddenly gone from
that yeah to that yeah but strange
you do ask our opinion now and you've
kind of gone
full circle i think and i think
it was all about us and the family and
then it became the mentors and what
you'd learnt and all this and going
abroad and doing all that
but now when we chat to you it is just
like old times
that's interesting i would agree with
that yeah
and it's funny as well you say that
because one of the things i've learned
is
actually how important it is to
um i just like remember where you came
from but
the people that know you absolute best
i mean some of the advice that i've had
from real big paid mentors that i've
paid hundreds of thousands of pounds has
been garbage
yeah it's been rubbish and
actually i think it's really important
and also just having that support and
having that
knowing that having that relationship i
think with family
is is mega and i'm really fortunate that
i get on with
everybody in the family both on dad's
side your side
there's no one in the family you know
yeah tiffany
russell obviously me and rustler a best
mate everyone on amanda side of the
family i come with everybody
but i think it's mega important and i
think it's really important to
if you have got family that are being
naysayers trying to hold you down
sometimes you have to not park company
but you just have to do your thing and
not listen
but if you've got a supportive family
you've got people that are rooting for
you
um i think that's one of the most
important things
in the world and i definitely know that
i wouldn't be where i am today not just
because of the initial few years of
property support but also just the
believing in me um right from a kid
you know and the whole way i was raised
to think and to believe in myself
i know that our business my business
would be
would be non-existent if it wasn't for
the advice the support
you know i've had from you guys so i'm
eternally grateful
well it's always a combination isn't it
of different facts yeah
yeah but um what would your advice be
to someone watching this that was maybe
if you were
um talking to a 17 year old kid now like
i was when i started
a 16 17 year old kid that had the hunger
that i had
but also was a situation where they
haven't got the money they haven't got
the ability to get a mortgage they
haven't got the
education and and this that and the
other
what advice would you give them to to
succeed in life and to succeed in
property
they've got to mix with property people
yeah
and just mix with them and talk to them
i remember lis watching you
16 and talking to a property investor
from up north and well known investor at
the time because his name escapes me
and i stood there thinking he's holding
his own without property investor does
that property investor actually know
he's only 80 or 17
did he know he's only 17 because no
one's known
yeah and he thought he'd thought you're
older than that but the fact
you did that other people need to do
that just talk to property investors and
get
you know you might only be 17. so what
yeah everyone's
every multi-millionaire every successful
person starts somewhere
yeah um you don't know who's going to be
going to make it in one sense
and who's going to have influence yeah i
think to be
i think one of the things you did a lot
of was
you used to write a lot of things down
didn't you yeah and you were quite clear
about what you wanted to do
yeah i think that's so important
because i think and and for anyone not
just a 17 year old
i think you sometimes just have to take
stock like we
wanted to live in the peak district we
might want to do that
more than somebody up it's making things
happen that you
want yeah that's important
so it's not following someone else
to the nth degree it's deciding what
you want and then going about that
do you get me yeah and then finding the
people that are going to help
and support you yeah in that yeah no i
think so i think getting around the
right people
believing in yourself um what because
what i everything i'm about now and
everything i teach is kind of like a
product of what i am
yeah you know even when people say you
know
i know you um we've spoken earlier about
the critics or whatever but
i'm only teaching what what i've done
yeah
so i i can't say it's gonna work for
every single person i know it's possible
to work for anyone because it's worked
for me and i've seen it with my students
i went on training when i couldn't
afford it i put stuff on credit cards as
a teenager with no comeback
it wasn't like hey if it doesn't work
out son
will sort you out no no i would have had
to have just
done paper rounds or started washing
cars to pay off the debt so
i did it i got trained it worked for me
i now have a successful property
business i now have a training company
but um yeah i just i mean i just
do my team i think the biggest thing for
anyone or
the biggest thing that i
would like to instill into a child yeah
is that
you must have the right attitude yeah
because that stands you in good stead
for everything yeah you're going to get
disappointments
yeah that is like if you live in this
life if you're breathing you're going to
get disappointment
yeah and it's how you handle that
now going away from property for a
minute
when you broke your knee in uganda
i think i really thought yeah
you've handled that so well because at
that point
you were not where you are now you were
doing well
with the training but you were putting
tremendous effort into that
you'd only just got home a week and you
were training people
yeah it was like an unstoppable attitude
a mission yeah but when
you've got something like that and a
mission
it's very easy to let things floor you
you know some things you can shake off
other things floor you
yeah and you're out but you don't
and i think that is that is a key that
is
do not let things flow you yeah
because i remember coming around your
house a week after you've had your
accident
you just got back from and just for the
record it wasn't just a breaking of a
knee it was
terrific you were told you were
50 chance you were never going to walk
again yeah and if i do walk again i'll
have a limp you'll be on a stick
yeah and all the rest of it so for a
young man of what 27.
lost 25 of my blood really really really
really bad
that could put someone in a depression
for two years
i remember thinking that
and i remember saying to you something
along the lines of
you know you're doing really well that
could have put you in a depression for
two years
but with the right attitude you can fast
track that
and you can get through things it didn't
put me in depression for a day did it
not
no no not at all and while i was in line
in hospital bed in uganda
i didn't have wi-fi but um
i managed to get some wi-fi i think when
i moved hospital
yeah remember for the last two days in
uganda i was in a different hospital
basically wi-fi
and uh people are messaging me and stuff
mostly nice by people
mocking me you know i had like haters
and online trolls and stuff
mocking me i've got a question for you
go on
how do you do that like when
everything seems when your whole world
seems to be
crumbling you know like
what what has someone got to do to break
your spirit basically
i think in all honesty i think being a
christian
yeah and knowing that actually life is
extremely short
yeah and you know
we are eternal beings and right now
life's eternal really really really
short
and knowing that what i'm doing is not
just for this lifetime it's actually for
eternity i don't mean to get all
spiritual on
my viewers but and just knowing that
actually am i doing what god's called me
to do
am i um
i think that's it that's it so yeah
if i am doing what god's called me to do
not just not just what i love doing but
what
i'm called to do yeah then it doesn't
really
and one of the sort of revelations i've
had especially with a lot of the the
criticism that i've had from the media
and stuff is just
i don't i don't answer to the media
i answered to god and i answered to my
family and i answered to my wife and
my you know what i mean so regardless of
the chatter
i'm just thinking well what are people
in my life saying
yeah you know and in terms of like the
leg injury or
some of the some of the the issues you
know car accidents
and and and severe near-death moments
and things yeah i think it's just
i'm i'm living a life on purpose yeah so
never ever was was i've been worried
about being comfortable
and i don't think you can be the kind of
person that wants to be comfortable
yeah if you want to be successful and
you want to be effective and you want to
leave a legacy
you you've got to get comfort completely
out of your mind
yeah so you know whether it's some
needing to make an awkward phone call or
decision or i'm needing to grow in my
business or whether it's i'm lining
a puddle of wee in uganda not being
changed and not eating for 10 days
and being told i could die okay well i
am
not about being comfortable right i
think that i think that's really what it
is
yeah um do you i'm not meant to be
asking the questions
god do you ever
procrastinate or think oh i don't feel
like doing that now
never never never never and if i do feel
like
i don't want to do something i don't do
it you don't do it nope
i don't do it but you never do it you
just don't have it let's no
if i'm working really hard and i'm like
oh man i'm tired i don't feel like
working anymore
i'll go and have a break okay but no i
never
ever procrastinate i just don't it's not
in
my and i only have a small amount of
goals
so i don't work on i don't have long to
do lists and this and i've got to do
this and i've
got to do that oh i just have
this is what i'm going to do yeah this
month
and if it's not towards that or these
one or two or maybe three things
then i'm not doing it i only ever have
two or three things at a time that i'm
doing
so i don't i can't procrastinate why do
you procrastinate
no but i'm just batting
the ideas around yeah
final words of wisdom than tim sorry to
put you on the spot
that's pretty much the sport where's my
zoom not in what respect
just for someone that wants to be just
for someone that wants to be
successful effective live a full life
you've done well in property you've
raised you've raised me
from the age 12 and and and helped me
and um yeah i mean you've you've taught
street kids and you've taught business
people
you if you have a heart it's hard to do
something you just go and do it
you gotta say well what am i interested
in that's what i'm gonna do
i know we went to lee moore it wasn't
my idea and i wasn't particularly
jumping with dan about it at the time
but i decided right don't moan about it
just get on with it i'm going to join
you too and what you're doing and those
are
three years of my life that i should
never forget because they're brilliant
to enjoy them so just get on and do it
don't harp on about
bad things yeah and i've i've had to go
through
my background being an accountant is so
regimented and
no risk averse i've mentioned before
i've changed from that
and my my parents back and i've had to
change my heart
it's a whole mindset i never expected
that happened when i married sue
yeah but life's been an adventure and i
think life is an adventure and make an
adventure
make what you call it you live once
as they say but make the best of it and
don't hop on about
the bad things just get on with life
yeah that's good advice that's good
advice
well it's been great chatting i think
we've just had
a similar kind of conversation to what
we would have probably off camera
pretty much this is typical us isn't it
different deep conversations
yeah deep conversations about life and
yeah but honestly you know it's really
great and
um no doubt we'll get you back on we are
going to be documenting one of your barn
conversions
which is going to be awesome and um yeah
exciting so again thanks for coming on
the show
thanks for investing in me as a person
and that's it it's a wrap yeah thank you
very much
i really enjoyed that interview i love
chatting with my parents
i hope you found it useful i hope you
found it interesting don't forget
i interview my success students when i
was a little bit of a different one
every single week and if you want to
hear more interviews like that then you
can check them out right here
also please do smash the like button
show some support
drop a comment and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel subscribe and
turn the notification bell on so you
never miss a video thanks so much i'll
see you next time